[Music]
state power therefore still lacks a will
with which to oppose council and the
power to decide which of the different
opinions is best for the general good it
is not yet a government and therefore
not yet in truth an actual state power
the being for self the will which an
will is not sacrificed is the inner
separated spirit of the various classes
and estates and this in spite of its
chatter about the general good reserves
to itself with suits its own best
interests and is inclined to make this
chatter about the general good a
substitute for a action the sacrifice of
existence which happens in the service
of the state is indeed complete when it
has gone as far as death but the hazard
of death which the individual survives
leaves him with a definite existence and
hence with a particular self-interest
and this makes his council about what is
best for the general good ambiguous and
open to suspicion it means that he has
in fact reserved his own opinion in his
own particular will in the face of the
power of the state his conduct therefore
conflicts with the interests of the
state and is characteristic of the
ignoble consciousness which is always on
the point of revolt
paragraph 506 is simply fascinating in
in the dynamic that Hegel is describing
here and I can think of a couple
historical examples that he probably has
very closely in mind and what we'll come
back to them in just a bit you know
thinking of France in the time before
louis xiv before you know state power
truly became consolidated and i'm
thinking about germany at the time of
the Wars of Religion you know where all
these electors were able to bollocks
things up pretty well and plunge Germany
into a civil war that made it the the
battleground of all these other
competing powers so Hegel talks here
about an underdeveloped state power
right it's not yet quite state power he
says why because it still lacks a will
with which to oppose Council now that's
an interesting way to put things as a
criterion for what would really be state
power
it doesn't lack an essential will as we
saw in the last paragraph it lacks a
particular will to oppose Council to say
no we're not going to do this I'm gonna
listen to these guys and you over there
enough talking get in line or you know
shut up or consider yourself in revolt
the the sort of you know the buck stops
here that allows adjudication to
actually happen and some sort of
decision to be made
notice that what Hegel opposes this to
is what he's going to call a little bit
later chatter about the general good
that winds up being a substitute for
action endless talk talk talk talk
talking right and it's interesting that
that Miller translates that as the
general good because what the Germany
has is
I'll give Ana beste the you know
universal or or you know common bests
here I think it's very good to think in
terms of the best and that that you know
phrase that we have of allowing the best
to become the enemy of the good which
generally means an ideal best that won't
be realized but which everybody talks
about and criticizes for not reaching
stands in the way of accomplishing some
sort of concrete good which is what
state power it for Hegel is ultimately
about if it's going to be something more
than just a mere tyranny if it's going
to help us realize our freedom it's
going to be about some sort of
substantive good and its realization so
what's going on
Hegel has already said in the previous
paragraph that there's no problem with
the law being developed what's missing
here is a government an effective
principle of decision of rulership this
doesn't mean that there's nobody there
in charge right it means that they're
ineffective it means that they're unable
to deal with the the various voices that
are all saying we should do this we
should do this we should do this notice
that it's what we're talking about here
is some sort of participatory albeit of
course in some you know imperfect way
but participatory way of handling all
the things that estate handles you know
who should we go to war with what is
what should our trade policy's be should
we tax people shouldn't we tax people
how about building some roads may be
some aqueducts maybe some some baths all
those sorts of questions that are that
are coming up inevitably so he says
state power lacks the power to decide
which of the different opinions is best
for the general good which of these
opinions should we listen to and which
should we say no to which should we ask
hey can you tell me more what what are
your plans how how would we pay for this
how
should we put this into practice what
are the what's the nitty-gritty of your
proposal that's the sort of thing that
governments have to ask and everybody
because they realize they can all talk
as much as they like is coming to the
government and giving some advice now
the problem is how do you determine
which advice is the best advice you do
need some advice right because if you
knew it all well you wouldn't need
anybody else giving input the very fact
that you're taking input isn't just
about everybody getting to feel like
they have a voice or as we say a seat at
the table or buy-in or anything like
that because if the the you know ruler
or the state power had it all figured
out they could just say everybody shut
the hell up I'm gonna decide we're gonna
do things this way you're gonna love it
but that's not what happens
and that's not what happens throughout
history right we see constantly people
asking other people well what do you
think well what should we do
we have councils this is that in German
council right so he says what's lacking
here the being for self the will which
as will is not sacrificed is the inner
separated spirit of what the various as
we're translating it here classes and
estates in German - tenda you know all
of these various interests that have
some sort of power basis or structure or
some authority you know and if we're
talking and now let's actually talk
about medieval Europe right what would
we be discussing there's that old
traditional division of you know the the
estates we all we can also talk about
you know the nobility the clergy the
burgers right the farmers you know and
some divided things into those who pray
those who defend those who farm and
I guess everyone else kind of fit in
there wherever there's always this
tendency like split you know groups into
their own associations based on
interests and and there can be a lot of
divisions within that right the nobility
some of them are traditionally rivals
with each other they represent different
areas they're trying to encroach on each
other's territory in the Middle Ages
when when the church actually holds a
lot of land you know Abbot's bishops
often our secular powers you see this in
the Song of Roland right where one of
the one of the the great war leaders is
this Bishop was going around cracking
people with his his uh I think he's got
a Mesa or he might have actually a sword
in that one all of these different
competing voices are each motivated by
their own particular interest so the
council that you're getting from them is
not disinterested they may in fact be
saying something that is for the common
good but they might also be saying
something to line their own pockets or
to improve their own power position or
to get a concession that matters in some
other realm altogether or they may just
be trying to stick it to their rivals
you know there's all these different
possibilities so he says that this this
is being for self the will is not
sacrificed we saw that in the last
paragraph the the will of the the noble
though the haughty vassal is not
sacrificed and this is the separated
spirit of the various classes in the
states this in spite of its chatter
about the general good reserves to
itself what suits its own best interest
and is inclined to make this chatter
about the general good a substitute for
action
we call this chatter about the general
good in our political system gridlock
and there are some people for whom
gridlock works great as a matter of fact
the financial interests for the most
part banks you know the insurance
companies
you know traders they love when there's
gridlock as a matter of fact so two law
firms you know why because gridlock
means that nothing new is really going
to happen to shake things up to
transform the society that we're looking
at gridlock reduces volatility which
helps to increase profits or at least
makes them more reliable more secure
gridlock doesn't work well for other
interests which are always trying to
overturn that this is a age-old dynamic
this doesn't just happen here in 21st
century late capitalist liberal
democracies it happened in the Middle
Ages as well there there were always
people looking to change things and
other people were like you know let's
balance these things off against each
other and everything will be nice and
good the way we like it so there's
always this this possibility of
particular interests you know winning
out now he goes on any tracks a bit
about the individual as well
he says the sacrifice of existence which
happens in the service of the state is
indeed complete when it has gone as far
as death
now who risks death does the burger
class risk death I mean I suppose you
could say that the burger class of a
particular City does when they take up
arms against their Lord or higher the
mercenaries who are going to fight
against you know the oppressive tax er
or something like that but for the most
part it's not the class or the estate
that is facing death
it's rather individuals and this
introduces another wrinkle right the
individual risks death faces desk death
fears death and the council that they're
gonna give is going to be affected by
that as well Hegel says that the hazard
of death which the individual survives
leaves him with a definite existence
hence with a particular self-interest
this makes his council about what is
best for the general good ambiguous and
open to suspicion everybody has got a
particular take and everybody's
particular take is something that it may
not be at odds with the general good but
it may certainly be deformed corrupted
go on astray to use Aristotle's language
so this is a perennial problem and if
you don't have some sort of decisive
strong principle here a will that is
conscious of itself as will as
government how are you going to decide
this do you just let one of these in and
let them become the the decider so he
goes on and he says here we go it means
that he is in fact reserved his own
opinion his own particular will in the
face of the power of the state so what
does this mean this means that the noble
individual starts to look a lot more
like the base individual he says that
this person's conduct conflicts with the
interests of the state and as
characteristic of the ignoble
consciousness which is always on the
point of revolt which is always trying
to get its own angle which is always
trying to make sure that it hedges its
own bats rather than trust in the state
and why would it in fact trust in a
state like this this is an interesting
issue in order to be able to trust in
the state or if we want to think in
terms of leadership in general any
organization in order to trust that
you're not going to get screwed over you
do in fact need leadership now it may
not be good leadership
it may be representing just one of these
classes or estates it may just be the
individual ruling for his or her own
benefit despotic alee and then you don't
buy into that right then you're like
okay I'll give you counsel
but it's going to cost you and it's
going to be to my benefit and I'll keep
something back as insurance just in case
you try to screw me over but if you do
have something that really is a worthy
state power or at least leadership well
then you've got something that becomes
quite tempting to tie yourself in with
to sacrifice more than just certain
external advantages - and then you're
posed with a real issue
I mentioned that we could talk about
historical examples I think louis xiv
provides us with an excellent example of
this we tend to think of louis xiv
because of the history books is he was
the Sun King he was in charge of
everything
you know France was there's this massive
power under his his reign and that's all
true what we leave out quite often is
the fact that Louie was forced to flee
France if I remember flee flee France
itself because of a revolution when he
was a youth and he saw that all of these
competing interests needed to be checked
that the only thing that could keep each
of them from trying to get their own
thing out of the state all of them were
sort of on the make all of them were
trying to take over the state and impose
their own governance was a strong
government that stood over and above
them and rained all of them in that was
the lesson that he learned that didn't
happen in Germany and still hadn't
happened in Germany at the time that
Hegel is writing the phenomenology he
will you know in effect tie himself in
with the Prussian state in part because
Prussia Bavaria and Austria were really
the only main contenders for having a
shot at unifying Germany at bringing
together all of these different classes
and interests it wasn't just about
unifying these these little territories
it was about finding some way to
together all of these different you know
SH tende in a state where they would you
know in fact just stop chattering
constantly about the common good and the
common good could in fact be realized so
what is the individual stance at this
point we we see a kind of shifting here
will they remain noble or will they go
into igg nobility well that's what we
have to look at next
this contradiction which being for self
must resolve that of the disparity
between its being for self and the state
power is at the same time present in the
following form that renunciation of
existence when it is complete as it is
in death is simply a renunciation it
does not return into consciousness
consciousness does not survive the
renunciation is not in and for itself
but merely passes over into its
unreconciled opposite consequently the
true sacrifice of being for self is
solely that in which it surrenders
itself as completely as in death yet in
this renunciation no less preserve as
preserves itself and thereby becomes an
actuality what it is in itself becomes
the identical you name itself and of its
opposed self the separated inner spirit
the self as such having come forward and
renounced itself the state power is at
the same time raised to the position of
having a self of its own without this
renunciation of self the deeds of Honor
the deeds of the normal consciousness
and the counsels based on its insight
would retain the ambiguity possessed by
that private reserve of particular
intention and self will
Hegel begins paragraph 507 by talking
about a contradiction evaders brook
between being for self and the state
power and the state power as we've seen
so far has not yet been realized as a
self it hasn't had a particular will
although it did have an essential will
and Hegel is going to tell us that this
contradiction has to be addressed being
for self is going to have to do this in
order to figure out what the hell it is
at this point in order to make sense of
its own being for self and in order to
have something that it considers
genuinely essential genuinely valuable
for it so how does it do this he tells
us that it does it through renunciation
through risking something and death
provides us with a model for so he says
renunciation of existence when it is
complete as it is in death is simply a
renunciation it leaves nothing behind so
that's not really a workable means for
for consciousness but if it only
renounces some of what it has then it
seems like it's caught in this position
of the the haughty vassal or noble right
the the noble consciousness that kind of
reserves to itself quite a bit of stuff
on its own and doesn't fully commit
itself and then it seems like virtue and
the way of the world is just being
repeated here isn't it that everybody is
really on the make it's just some people
call themselves Noble and some people
are more honest about it
is there another possibility could it be
something other than death
that happens in this renunciation what
if you did renounce your entire self as
well as your possessions as well as your
position and you got it back that should
actually remind us of something that
happens in Kierkegaard of course
in fear and trembling but you know I'll
just pass over that here just you know
keep that in mind when people say how
totally opposed Hegel and Kierkegaard
are so he says here the issue is that
when there's a running renunciation that
does not return into consciousness
consciousness does not survive the
renunciation it does not become in and
for itself but merely passes over into
its unreconciled opposite so what if
consciousness truly sacrifices being for
self but it at the same time manages to
preserve itself by getting itself back
this sort of loyalty which is what we're
talking about here is not possible in
every circumstance and as a matter of
fact would be ill-advised in many
circumstances you know Hegel is a big
proponent of things having to come at
their proper time and in the proper
conditions for history it's not like you
can simply force the dialectic by
deciding okay I like this stage better
we're going to jump right there
consciousness has to have something that
it can actually pin its hopes upon in
this case and so that is is what it's
going to be looking at so here he says
what does it do if it is able to
renounce and preserve itself it becomes
he calls that the identical unity of
itself and it's opposed self the
separated inner spirit itself is such
coming forth renouncing itself that's
all great that's going to have to do a
state power but what's going on down
here between the self and the opposed
self is this the self and the other is
this the dialectic of self consciousness
again the struggle for recognition how
are these being harmonized what are we
talking about here is state power the
opposed self
is the ignoble self-consciousness the
opposed self Hagel doesn't actually tell
us at this point so we're gonna have to
see what he says in the next paragraph
or so but that's a really interesting
challenge to think about isn't it now
what does happen the state power is
finally being constituted as a self as a
particular will as being for itself no
longer merely in itself as conscious
conscious as being state power ah now
that's a very different sort of thing to
to align yourself with to identify
yourself with to it so it makes
sacrifice to to engage as Hegel says in
deeds of heroism noble deeds honorable
deeds and in giving counsel now notice
that he says that if this doesn't happen
he says without this renunciation of
self then the the deeds of the noble
consciousness and the counsels based on
its insight would retain the ambiguity
the dull polite the you know the dolls
in the doubling process by that private
reserve of particular intention itself
well if it doesn't entire this is where
you have to make a moment of decision
the noble self consciousness can only
truly be the noble self consciousness if
it totally commits itself otherwise it's
really at risk for being a disguised
form of the ignoble self-consciousness
just telling itself that it's Noble and
listening to the chatter of everybody
you know honoring it and saying oh
you're such a sweet you know such a
great guy you know so wonderful how you
did those great deeds and provide that
wonderful counsel so absolute commitment
we see this in Hegel over and over again
this theme that the ethical really does
require absolute commitment absolute you
know renunciation but in this case
there's there's a recovery there is a
recuperation that's taking place that
now allows a different relation of the
noble self conscious
to state power precisely because state
power itself has also changed in the
process
you